poi giù amici miei voi ci siamo sul
gioco molto bella molto più già vecchia
l'obbligo di tirar la palla in buca
ma le difficoltà è un esempio di 100
gravissimo è sempre più difficile perché
ci sono degli ostaggi questo è un gioco
di golf dove ci sono degli ostacoli o
sul tipo ad esempio ci sono le robe nel
mezzo
vi assicuro che non è così facile adesso
proviamo a prendere la palla andrè di la
famiglia elettroswing come te la cavi
con lo swing fratello vai fammi vedere
bravo bravo bravo bravissimo è proprio
quello che pensavo e io devo lanciare me
stesso va bene ha un proprio io so io
sono una palla no pensavo di non avevo
capito quindi è un gioco di golf non
convenzione c'è nel senso tu devi fare
le cose ma non come pensi che io ero la
palla maledizione alla vita ogni guarna
bella botta bravo la mazza è arrivata
quasi al traguardo su cui vogliamo dirla
tutta però vai vai bravissimo
complimenti pedina cicinìn proprio di la
bravo aux aia va bene adesso non c'è il
tizio c'è solo la mazza va bene posso
provare a tirare trent li bravo ecco no
è difficilissimo però mi sa che stavolta
non ci arrivo
e invece si arrivò sono bravissimo ecco
l'obiettivo da colpire cosa sono adesso
la casa sono la casa va bene lanciamo
una casa ai buca è quello l'obiettivo è
quello cioè ogni livello e un po se hai
capito quindi devi fare un po di all in
one va bene
qua ci sono la pallina quindi sarà la
pallina immagino però è molto più
difficile di prima pero bello ce n'è
l'obiettivo non è il palla entra nella
buca e parla arrivare alla alla bandiera
brutta stronzo ragazzi il gioco
dell'anno
questo qua per me per me vale tutti i
soldi spesi attenzione band flag
bandiera cattiva la madonna poi immagino
che sia a livello un po incasinato
sbaglio madonna reggio incredibile spero
che duri pil in episodio
e vabbè succedono robe avere ora la
introverso guarda i gol più divenne la
sola intro bene mi ha intrattenuto un
sacco anche sulla hit
penso allora l'ho pagato 15 euro e voi
direte ma scusatemi ma lui dice euro per
un gioco così non li merita tutti ciao
pallina gli darei anche 30 tra sicuro
continua di sprone il lavoratore subito
bene permesso vado ciao e il gioco di
golf più strano che abbia mai visto la
mia vita l'esperimento olsson gioco
vediamo che senso ha ok
devo entrare li ha quindi tu sei nei
laboratori e scegli le varie mappe da
fare sono una roccia a figo avevo capito
sono entrato buca in uno ma non è vero
ha quindi tu entri e ti fai vari livelli
così bellissimo
che idea assurda ragazzi che spero che
duri un sacco perché lo voglio fare
tutto questo lo voglio finire tipo lo
prendo come se fosse un super meat boy
va bene ci sono studiate un sacco di
cose o va bene ma vai a mandarle tutte
in buca club
bastava una unione l'altra bellissima st
rocchi idea chiesto utilizzo bio bio
lancia gatto lancia gatto occhio che
cade come gli è venuto in mente una cosa
dei concorsi in geniale come è possibile
ragazzi andiamo a destra perché non ho
schiacciato devi spingere tanto con un
fronte ai chili così sta roba
accesso negato va bene fa niente
entriamo nella roba lì se devo dare il
power il computer se non funziona sono
la mela anno sono telecomando lo so il
divano tutto il divano va bene ragazzi
non ho il dl non so neanche come
descrivere tutta semplicità insieme sono
tutta la scrivania adesso la serie a
sono la sedia quindi con le rotelle
aiuto o chiocchio devo cambiare
direzione nel mentre che sono un casino
aiuto
vai a quella fisica da dio è fatta
quindi perfetto
e vabbè non cadere ok perfetto cerio 6
ott
se la traduzione in italiano in
fattibile perché fanno tutti gli sketch
con l'inglesismo italiano non vuol dire
niente sono la tv con attaccato il
lettore dvd va bene credo che questo sia
da almeno un anno a questa parte il
gioco più geniale giuro più geniale che
abbia mai fatto non sto scherzando qua
sono tappeto scommetti lo sogni vaso ma
non si deve rompere minchia al casinò
[Musica]
allora piano bravo bravo city stendino
ti rompi bravissimo bravo perfetto il
gioco based sono un vaso e fatemi fare
l'altra parte prima di tornare in riva
destra che devo a ma io mi sa che sono
due parti tutti e due lunghi allo stesso
modo davvero la sinistra ci torno dopo
dai bellissimo comunque dicevo è da un
anno a questa parte probabilmente il
gioco più geniale che ho giocato non lo
sto scherzando veramente questo è
veramente fatto bene 15 euro gliene
avrei dati in molti di più ma sono tutte
le palline tu te ne basta una alla
scatola sulla scatola occhio sono la
scatola di palline va bene quindi le
palline non centralmente unboxing
spacchetta o li va bene allora qua mi
lancio di nuovo io immagino non sono la
freccia o no vabbè dai ragazzi non so
cosa dire non so cosa dire no noi tutti
i soldi del mondo di lo studio veramente
altro che quindi ci viene dai motivi più
o attivato la corrente
la prima manca l'altra in 2d
aiuto e come vado su ok
2 di bellissimi no vabbè vabbè aiuto no
vabbè dai no di cosa parliamo ragazzi di
la genialata del no dai rainone non so
cosa dire e sta roba
ma come io no povero gatto come gli è
venuto in mente clip tiger estremo no
ragazzi incredibile
andiamo avanti sono innamorato di questo
ve lo giuro sono innamorato di voi
fatemi delle fan arte questa roba
bellissimo
va bene è questa la vedo un po
complicata come cosa vera ma devi che
traggo tutte ma savona
ci sono delle con quella non era che una
parte quella roba che el e non è neanche
una pallina è rimasta solo una va bene
balls bravo nella traduzione di balls
bravo prove non è un gioco di stile un
gioco di righi mamma milano alti livelli
non vedo l'ora accesso garantito c'è una
mucca li ragazzi che non ho ben capito
c'è un tipo un boss
ciao pallina fa vedere che cosa hai
chiarito che senso anti devo far vedere
le mie skillen di quello porca vacca ok
punto interrogativo aiuto
meno male e vabbè buono buono no non ci
credo ma che sfiga tremenda sta roba ok
l'ho fatto per te come ciccio gamer però
secondo me se tiro dritto sbaglia quindi
chi lo storto lo sapevo che lì c'è la
gravità a destra
avevo quasi fatta tirando storto
l'attenzione
ok va bene
l'ultimo stop per favore continuiamo a
giocare ce l'ho fatta
mi ha fatto passare grazie dio e sposo
tutto bene ciao mooncup cosa estero o
ragazzi bellissimo bellissimo e quindi
ogni tot ci sono livelli diversi
bellissimo questo era il primo veramente
sono stufi la bandiera e tra l'altro
vinto perché ho sbagliato ho sbagliato
tiro tirata dritte alla badia si è
spostata verso di me quindi ottimo vedo
delle robe vedo delle robe accesso
negato quindi questa un altro giro va
bene fa mettere nello spazio vediamo
come ragazzi 9 aiuto c'è una balena con
una buca sopra attenzione concentrarla
presa non l'ho presa l'hanno presà è
difficilissimo poi l'ho presa devo
andare sull'altro no vabbè la gravità
che che cambia bellissimo space a sono
un mix di tiri nello spazio che proprio
questo
beh meno male che c'è la traiettoria
sono google che ce la farei bellissima
ragazza roba bellissimo
ok la gravità dei carichi riti cambia
bellissimo ok
vabbè ragazzi facevano così visto che se
episodi è stato a dir poco epico direi
che continua nel prossimo perché ho
provato un bel po di livelli o ragazzi
gioco dell'anno maggio greca ote non
mettete mi piace a questo io me ne vado
mettete voglio un milione di mi piace
giusto ville voglio dovete condividerlo
con tutti i vostri amici tutti sto video
è la vita
per questo gioco incredibile quindi io
porterò sicuramente un altro episodio
non vedo l'ora zimbra mente allora
guardate me lo vedo portare l'altro
episodio spero che vi sia piaciuto
continuare il prossimo non vedo l'ora di
vedere che cosa ci propone sto gioco ma
veramente incredibile quanto si avvicina
maggiormente mi piace iscrivetevi al
canale lasciate un commento qui sotto
e noi ci vediamo a lungo seguito bella
ragazzi
[Musica]